For 146 years.
The Barnum and Bailey circus was known for being the greatest show on earth.
None of it would've been possible if it were not for an ambitious entrepreneur
who was named p t Barnum while his life and career where sometimes the source of
controversy.
He truly was a brilliant businessmen and many of his ideas forever changed the
entertainment industry as we know it today.
Phineas Taylor Barnum was born in 1810 in Bethel,
Connecticut.
His parents,
Filo Barnum is Irene Taylor were fallen is he rents now rooms in their home for
a bit of extra income.
His grandfather was a well respected judge in the town.
On the day of his baptism,
PT Barnum inherited a 4.6 acre piece of land from his grandfather called Ivy
Island.
His parents,
they were poor,
but as a child he grew up believing that he was the richest kid in town because
he thought that he had inherited a private islands somewhere where he could
build a house someday.
When he was 10 years old,
his parents finally took him on a trip to visit the islands where he discovered
this.
It was virtually worthless.
The island was simply muddy land in the middle of a swamp and it was filled with
poisonous snakes,
ticks and poison ivy.
He never did anything with that land today.
It's now part of a nature reserve called the Bethel Land Trust.
This was clearly disappointing to young Barnum and it left him yearning for a
reality where he truly would be rich enough to buy a private islands,
but he wasn't interested in the traditional ways of making money.
By his own admission,
had the reputation of being the laziest volume town because he hated doing farm
work and any sort of manual labor.
Instead of forcing Phineas into caring for the family farmer,
his father helped him get a job as a clerk in the town grocery store.
This was a perfect fit and Phineas grew to love the idea of running his own
business.
When he was only 15 years old,
his father died and he was now the man of the family.
This motivated and even more to make as much money as he possibly could.
He was possessed by the entrepreneurial spirit since he began trying different
business ventures right away.
His most successful business as a teenager was running a lottery while working
in the grocery store.
He has an endless supply of glass bottles and 10 advertising trays that he was
expected to simply throw away.
He knew that these items would be useful in people's homes and he wanted to
recycle them in some way,
but people,
they were not interested in buying these things.
Second hand,
he started selling tickets for a lottery.
Instead,
he promised that half of the tickets sold would be guaranteed to win something.
There were a few big cash prizes and also the Constellation prizes were the
items that he got for free.
He sold a thousand tickets in the first week and he continued to run the lottery
over and over again.
When he just 16 years old,
he used all the money he earns from these lotteries to move to Brooklyn,
New York to open his own grocery store.
Unfortunately though he calls small pox and had to move back to Connecticut so
his mother could help nurse him back to health.
After recovering from his illness,
he knew he needed to try again.
When he was 18 he opens up a confectionary store in his hometown that's sold
fruit and candy.
He was able to run more lotteries from this store.
He married his first wife charity Hallot when he was 19 years old and she was 21
they would eventually go on to have four daughters together.
Well and he never really was overly romantic.
He did rise that his wife was a treasure and to that without charity I am
nothing and he was 21 he wrote several passionate articles about politics and
sending them into the local newspaper bus.
They were all rejected.
He decided that if no one was going to publish as well,
he was self published,
his own paper goals,
Harold freedom.
He had enough money to buy his own printing press and he handed out the
newspapers in town and one of his articles,
he exposed the corrupt leaders of the towns,
local church,
the man suit and for liable,
and since he had no proof to back up his claims in court,
he ended up paying a $100 fine and spent 60 days in jail.
When he was released,
he became a local hero and a leader of the liberal movements.
Everyone loved him in Bridgeport because he decided that he achieved all he
could possibly achieve in Connecticut.
He wants it to move to New York City where he knew he would have many more
opportunities to earn a fortune
PT and charity bond and bought a boarding house in New York City so that they
could earn some income by renting out their extra rooms just like his parents
had done back and Canasta goes.
He used his knowledge from working in retail to have partial ownership of a
grocery store without having to do any of the work and he continued to run his
weekly lotteries.
He had set himself up in a pretty great financial situation and he was still
only in his early twenties his family,
these basic needs of food and housing,
when mass spurs his sites were on bigger and better ways to make as much money
as he possibly could.
When he was 25 years old,
he met a man who told him about Joyce half who was [inaudible] elderly African
American slave women.
She claims to be George Washington's nanny and it would go on and on with our
stories of that time together.
If this was true,
it would make a 161 years old.
Barnum was able to pay a owner $1,000 in order to put her on display.
She looked so incredibly old so that people actually believed that she may truly
have been 161 people came from all over New York City to see her.
She died after only one year of touring.
There was a public autopsy that revealed she was only about 80 years old,
but people,
we're not angry about the deception.
While it was a humbug.
People,
they still enjoyed the spectacle.
This gave PT Barnum a preview of the Shaman experience.
If he could find even more fantastic and interesting attractions.
He didn't have to do any of the hard manual labor that he dreaded so much.
He could just hire talented people to perform and to collect the money from
ticket sales.
PT Barnum trying to sell tickets to acts with performers who specialized in
juggling and his plate spinning,
but most of these shows they didn't do well because people had seen these acts
before.
He realized that he had gotten very lucky with having Joyce half.
This is very first attraction.
People wanted to pay for something they had never seen before that he had a
difficult time figuring out what to look for without having any experience in
the entertainment industry.
My name is 26 he temporarily left behind his wife and children to join a
traveling circus in order to educate himself on everything that he needed to
know about show business.
The owner of the circus was a man named Aaron Turner runs bone and told him that
he was eager to learn more about the business.
It's only designed it to give him firsthand experience with getting your crowns
attention.
The day before the opening show turn up pointed at PT Barnum when he was
standing in front of a crowd claiming that Barnum was reverend [inaudible]
Avery,
who was well known in the newspapers for the acquitted of murder.
Everyone knew that Avery was truly guilty and as they were all talking about
him,
not many people actually knew what he looks like,
but they all passionately hated this man.
Of course,
people believed Turner's Clayman's.
They began chasing after and he started running away the angry mob.
It got bigger and bigger and they weren't ready to take justice into their own
hands by lynching the murderer at the last moment,
Aaron,
it shouted that they were circus performance and that it was all a practical
joke.
Even though this could have been seen as bad publicity and it actually works.
Everyone in the town was talking about the angry mob and once it to know what
kinds of crazy men would pull such dangerous jokes on each other.
They bought tickets to the show.
The very next day after six months with the circus Barnum and started his own
small troupe of traveling performance called Barnum's,
grand scientific and a musical theater.
He even bought a steam boat to give tours and musical performances along the
river in the south,
but after about a year of living on the road,
he became very homesick.
He missed his wife and his children and he wanted stability.
He returns in New York hoping to find a way to display curiosity,
isn't performances without traveling from place to place
in 1841 barn and purchased the scutters American Museum and transformed it to be
a much more appealing place to visit.
The added flags to the outside and creators and elaborate a rooftop garden where
a hot air balloon gave people rides on a daily basis in science.
He had a knowledge array of exotic animals,
magicians,
and miniaturized recreation's of famous battles.
Pt Barnum was a genius when it came to getting more people to come to his
attractions.
When the American museum first,
he wasn't selling as many tickets as he hoped,
so he founds an unemployed man and paid him to run three ways,
cycle of various movements.
He would pick off a break on the street,
carry it to the door,
show his tickets to the museum,
ends,
walk inside.
Then he would walk back out again,
place the brick back down,
pick up another,
and it's continued to do this every single day to the point where people notice
this ritual on their way to and from work.
Some with even stopped to wash the mat and ask what he was doing.
It was enough to get people curious enough to buy a ticket for themselves so
they could see what was going on inside.
As time went on bone and use the money he made from ticket sales to improve the
quality of his displays.
He added one of his most famous hoaxes,
the Fiji Mermaid.
He claims that it was the body of the money that had been caught off the coast
of Fiji,
but it was really actually the skeleton of a monkey sewn on to a fish tail.
One of his most popular live exhibits was known as the freak show.
While some people disapprove of the fact that the exploited people with physical
abnormalities like bearded ladies and people with extra limbs,
he was given.
Many of these people work when they would have otherwise never found a job.
He also paid his employees very well and they were all treated like members of
the family.
Every single one of the members of the so called freak shows became incredibly
rich and all they had to do with stand on display.
Some of them chose to retire after just a few years of working and they went on
to get married and have very normal lives.
One Barnum was 33 years old,
had been running his American museum for a few years and it found some success,
but it was always looking for the next big thing.
He mentioned,
I'll Stratton who was one of his distant cousins.
Charles was only four years old when they match.
He was a proportion dwarf standing only at 25 inches tall.
He would stay the size of a baby for the rest of his life.
Charles,
his father was a carpenter,
so their family did not have a lot of money.
They were afraid for that son's future because not many dwarves could find work
outside of the entertainment industry and they were never the star of the show
anyway.
They were always just on the sidelines used as the butt of a joke.
PT Barnum agreed to be his cousin's manager and spent months teaching him how to
sing,
dance and act.
It was not sure how well the audiences would enjoy the show.
So at first he paid the boy's parents $3 a week,
which is the modern day equivalent of about $70.
His parents agreed and they were just happy that their young son could,
uh,
in any money at all.
Pt Barnum strategy with Charles,
his performance was to make him have the polar opposite of what people expected
from a dwarf.
He gave the boy at the stage name of Tom Thumb after the well loved English
fairy tale.
He also claims that he was already 10 years old instead of five,
which made us small snapchat even more incredible.
Thankfully Charles was a very smart child and he picked up on how to talk with
the bigger vocabulary of a 10 year old rather than a five year olds.
Barnum advertised Tom Thumb as a tiny gentlemen and dressing him men tailormade
suits.
He was able to memorize complicated lines and performed roles of dignified
figures in history like Napoleon Bonaparte.
It works a treat.
He traveled all over the United States and Europe.
It becoming one of the world's first international celebrities,
even at Queen Victoria was a fan of this Tom Thumb.
As time went on,
PT Barnum hired other proportion dwarves to join his American museum and this is
where Charles straps and message future wife Lavinia Warren Bond and threw them
a wedding ceremony but became front page news presidents.
Abraham Lincoln was also a huge fan and threw them a honeymoon party at the
White House strategy,
made so much money through performing.
He could have retired at a very young age,
but he genuinely enjoyed it and he continued until he died.
At the age of 45 the museum became so popular that people would buy once I get
and stay there all day.
Even if they got to the end of the tour,
it would get so crowded at the bottom,
had to figure out a way to trick people into believing.
He put up a sign that said this way to the egress.
People assumed that this was a way to another attraction,
but the grass is just a fancy word for access.
Once they left the building,
they could no longer open the door and if they wanted to come back inside,
they needed to stand in line and buy another tickets
up to having so much success with his American museum bond was able to build a
massive palace and can advocate for his family to live.
He called the home Iran has done because if it's Middle Eastern inspiration and
model of the building after the Brighton and Royal Pavilion in England,
which was the summer home of George Prince of Wales,
he was able to host events and bring in Themis guests from around the worlds
like the author Mark Twain.
He used the large halls for musical performances.
He believes that by building such a huge castle,
famous musicians would be more likely to perform at his venues and it absolutely
worked in eating 50 PT Barnum traders like it,
finding musical talent from overseas.
He convinced Steve Swedish opera singer named Jenny Linz to come to New York to
perform.
According to his autobiography,
Jenny Lens only agreed to travel to the United States because she saw the
engraving of Iran has done on the invitation letter and she wanted to visit this
intriguing palace.
He had never heard her sing,
but he learns of her reputation when visiting Europe.
Barnum was taking a huge risk by hiring Jenny Lind,
especially since he had no experience in the music industry,
even paid in advance to travel to the u s the barn used his marketing genius to
hype up our rivals so much less Americans believed she was one of the greatest
singers in the wells and that they would be foolish to miss a limited time
performance.
He created posters that to the Swedish Nightingale,
how fast performance was held in the castle garden and tickets sold out.
The shows were so popular.
Jenny Lens performed with Barnum 93 times over the course of five months.
This new found fame gave her enough momentum to hire a new manager and on a
world tour,
Bonnen was taking a cut of the ticket sales,
Jenny Linz and $350,000 while she was working with barn and for those few months
and she went on to make even more during our tour volume received $500,000 which
is the modern day equivalent of nearly $15 million,
tragically in 1857 men who are hard to do repairs on Iran.
Istan Wild Barnum was aware.
New York,
that's a pipe burning when they left for the day and it caused a fire that
destroyed everything has an insurance policy,
was only paid out to $28,000 even though it costs over 150,000 to build the
mansion.
And then in 1865 the American museum burned down as well.
He rebuild the museum that after only being open for a couple of years,
that burned down for a second time.
Barnum said the fires burned to the ground,
all of his life's accomplishments,
60 years old,
PT Barnum's life was a rollercoaster of success and failure.
He was at an age when most men would decided to cut their losses and just
retire.
But one of the many things that made PT Barnum Icentra success was that he
didn't ask his failures,
stop him from moving forward.
His children all grown up and his wife charity had sadly passed away.
He decided that the time was right in his life to start a traveling circus.
He was the very first circus owner to buy his own trains,
move the performers and equipment from place to place.
He paid his work as well and he made sure to use bright,
colorful,
elaborate 10 sends equipments which would attract crowds.
His first traveling show was called PT Barnum's,
Grand Traveling Museum,
Monogatari Caravan and hippodrome.
This had many of the same attraction and see once had in as American museum only
on a much grander scale.
People outside of New York City.
We're able to see his freak show,
his animal Menachem juries,
and is impressive acrobats that he had collected over the years of networking
and making friends in show business in 1881 when he was 71 years old,
he joins up with another circus which was owned by James Bailey ans they're
combined and cuts became the famous Barnum and Bailey,
the greatest show on earth.
They were the first three ring circus meaningless.
They would have three different acts going on at the same time.
One of his biggest attractions at the Barnum and Bailey Circus was jumbo,
the elephant.
He was one of the most popular animals for children in London and his kids in
America.
They felt the same way.
Everyone was mesmerized by the massive scale of the circus and they only
continued to improve upon the show.
As time went on,
the Barnum and Bailey circus continued to talk long after his death ending in
2017 it went on for 146 years.
As he grew older,
fewer and fewer people criticized PT Barnum for the tricks that he played on
audiences and more people recognize the impact that he made on the entertainment
industry.
He was well respected by just about everybody.
He wrote four books in his later years,
including one called the art of money getting and another book humbugs if the
wells.
He was very candid about psychics and magicians tricks and even called out Harry
Houdini.
He knew all the tricks of the trade as a route that he would pay $500 to any
medium who could truly convinced him that they were actually talking to the
debt.
There's point was that even though we know that magic and ghosts are not real,
that doesn't mean we can't enjoy the spectacle.
Very few people know that PT Barnum took politics very seriously,
especially in his later years and his autobiography he wrote to this man who
takes no interest in politics,
is unfit to live in our lands where the government rests in the hands of the
people.
In 1865 US congress would be voting on the amendment of the Constitution to
outlaw slavery.
Technically,
he has once been a slave owner himself with Joyce half,
but he now worked with and love of so many African American performers that he
felt passionately about fighting for their freedom and to use his money and
connections to join the Republican Party as part of the Connecticut legislature
chat.
He wanted to do everything within his power to help end slavery in the United
States and they succeed at the time he spends on the Connecticut legislature.
Wasn't the end of his political career though.
In 1875 he became the mayor of Bridgeport,
Connecticut and he served for one year and he was getting older,
PT Barnum page,
a reporter from the local newspaper to write if very flattering eulogy so that
he could hear and enjoy it while he was still alive.
He died in 1891 of a stroke of 79 years old.
He loves his job so much that he was working up until the day he died and his
last words were a request to look over some receipts.
Two years after his death,
a statue,
it's spelled in seaside park in Bridgeport can as it goes on land that he had
donated to the city today.
His legacy still lives on in the minds and hearts of everyone who remembers the
circus and his workers influenced entertainments as we know it throughout the
world.
So really,
have you enjoyed that video?
If you did,
please do subscribe to this channel.
We've got brand new biographic videos like this all the time.
That's what this channel is for.
That's what we do.
Also check out some other ones linked to on the screen now and as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.